one night I I messed up and I left a
fish I like cleaned this fish I ate like
this huge fish I just ate it to my face
you're putting out like Marathon levels
of of energy every day like you know
Goggins would love solos this is awesome
yeah you eat the fish Raw uh this one I
actually cooked it but you know the
skeleton was laying there right right
outside my tent stupid yeah and in the
middle of the night I wake up and I just
could tell there was something there you
know and then like you almost don't want
to look it's like when you're a kid at
the basement door and you're like is
there a ghost it's like I like unzip the
tent and I like open it up and there's
like 27 black caiman outside of my tent
all looking at me like this and like
some of their heads are this big and
they're like there's fish there can we
have it and I'm like holy and like
you know I was like do I I kind of like
had to like scooch the tent back and
like move back and let them have their
fish and there's a host of crocodiles
outside of my tent yeah
um but no so then there's three how many
like 27 maybe there's a lot big ones
small ones medium sized one every type
thing we're all there and their eyes
glow in the night you know you shine a
light at animals and they have a taping
them lucidum and so their their eye
shine comes back at you if you shine a
headlamp at a at a jaguar or a frog or
almost every animal has a tape in them
so he's a Croc there's a whole lot of
them yeah I thought can we go back to
the part of the conversation where you
said the jungle is not dangerous the
humans are the most dangerous did they
eat me no why didn't they eat you they
wanted the fish is there some way of you
interacting with them that shows that
you're not social harm
I don't believe so I'm sure there's
someone out there that thinks they can
talk to Crocs but because there's a
there's a story of you grabbing a Croc
by the tail yes what did you learn from
that learn to not always listen to JJ so
JJ was testing you to uh yeah to see how
stupid it was how did you hold the
crocodile exactly you have to get them
by the head like an anaconda like this
and so so you're one of the world
experts to grabbing creatures by the
head I wouldn't say World expert but
I've done a lot of it um I also have you
see that there's like kind of a ball
there that's where a crocodile tooth
went in that side and like came out that
side of my house that was a really good
Chomp and the watch I was wearing at the
time
saved me because that like that
um real fast just Chomp just whack like
somebody took a sledgehammer you put
your hand on the table and I just went
really hurt
um shouldn't have been doing that what
how did that come up because I caught a
crock that was too big so usually when
we catch little Caiman in the streams
and we measure them to monitor the
populations
um you get it by the neck and then I
tuck the tail under my arm and I hold it
and you're talking about a little you
know four foot Croc nothing and I I this
one I dove into a into a swamp and I
caught like a six foot
spectacle Cayman and her head was big
and I had her by the neck and I realized
I couldn't get her tail under my arm
because her tail was all the way back
there and she started thrashing
and it was like probably Croc number 375
that I'd caught and I just got a little
cocky and I said ah she's you know I
just I just like grabbed her by a leg I
was like I got this and she just came
back and tagged me and I went okay gonna
go back to being safe just to linger on
it what uh
is it one of the one of the bigger
predators in the Amazon what and it's is
it going to uh are they going extinct
black caimans black caiman were I
believe they were critically endangered
for a while because for a while the
fashion industry loved their skin it's
soft and it's black
um they're bouncing back a little bit
now you know like most animals if you
leave them alone they'll be fine I mean
Crocs have been through you know how
many millions and millions of years on
Earth before us I mean that's even the
joke with with the joke but that's the
Grim reality of tiger conservation it's
there was a hundred thousand Tigers in
1900.
now this 4 000 Tigers left on Earth
it's not rocket science all you have to
do is not bulldoze their forest and
allow there to be some deer and tigers
will be fine that's it it's so simple
and that's like sometimes where I feel
like I have the dumbest job in the world
I'm like guys please stop killing the
things that Keep Us Alive
the Amazon regulates our Global Climate
produces medicine is home to indigenous
people it's beautiful
rainforests only cover three percent of
the planet's land mass like it's not
that much to ask
if you uh leave their home untouched
they'll figure out how to have sex and
multiply except for pandas apparently
because pandas you have to convince yeah
uh humpbacks humpbacks they went down to
they went from 130 000 down to I think
about 8 000.
at whaling times and then when we banned
whaling since that time where I think
we're back up to over a hundred thousand
humpback whales they've bounced back
it's a success story we're not going to
lose them
okay so you're in on a solo
with uh Crocs looking at you see this is
why you're good at this you know I I
would have lost we would have been no
that's pretty ever with the fish that
was your mistake that was my mistake I
don't understand how you're still alive
I mean I
it's really inspiring when you come
we're gonna I'm gonna show you
you told me you're coming around you're
100 coming yeah but you know
if there's any place I mean
um
a sort of a grim joke but if there's any
way to die uh that's a good one if I'm
being honest it's a cool one it's a
pretty cool one it'll become part of the
part yeah yeah I mean there's it's I'm
not even like joking there's a there's a
Oneness to the whole thing
ever all the stories just reading your
work looking at your work I
it seems like you are part of this
machine that is nature the this this
incredible
machine like we all die
and we're all part of this big thing
that humans do have the capability to
also construct narratives and stories
and myths and tell them to each other
and share them with each other and have
more sophisticated ways therefore to
communicate love to each other but
animals do as well they communicate love
maybe more simply
maybe more honestly
anyway so you're you were the Crocs and
the fish
yeah so I messed up I left the fish out
Croc showed up outside my tent but in
the end it was fine I I backed off they
had their way with the fish and then
they all started biting each other it
was fun to watch is it a general story
to interrupt is that a general rule you
want to not leave
yeah just like if you're camping in the
Northeast you don't leave like you do a
bear bag or a bear canister you don't
you don't want to invite the wild
animals I really did mess up I kind of
was just like you know whatever I do
this every now and then I get a little
too Cavalier
um and that the ocean has had almost
almost taken me down for that a few
times